[Music]
you are looking at a best buy store in
new jersey this morning where early
black friday shoppers are trying to snag
some deals it's estimated americans
could spend up to 859
billion dollars this holiday season wow
and in many cases they are spending more
than they intend that sounds familiar
now there's a new option to pay for
items called buy now pay later as mark
strossman reports the apps are popular
with younger shoppers
black friday shop till you drop or for
millions of americans until their credit
cards max out but if you're shopping
online this year you've probably noticed
new payment options companies like after
pay clarna and affirm michelle sweet's
favorite
it was very simple
very easy to navigate outside raleigh
north carolina sweet used a firm a
couple dozen times to finish her
christmas shopping early it's kind of
like they are giving you
the control of how you want to repay
them based on your budget and what you
can afford a firm is a so-called bnpl
credit companies that let you buy now
pay later
one in six americans shopping online may
use a bnpl this holiday season it's
basically a credit card replacement
uh we have a couple of advantages
billionaire max levchin a co-founder of
paypal launched a firm in two thousand
twelve the san francisco-based company
now has almost nine million active
customers
we built the whole idea around the
notion that consumer finance is so
complicated and so convoluted
consumers lose money and lose sleep over
just uncertainty what things actually
cost unlike a credit card a firm
underwrites each transaction separately
in real time interest rates from zero to
30 percent simple interest not compound
payment options 60 days to 60 months
and you know the total cost up front no
fees no gotchas no regrets is the
tagline we've used in the past
you would say one of the virtues is it's
transparency that is the virtue you pay
it over time and you know what you're
going to pay exactly
also buying in more than one hundred
thousand merchants including giants
walmart target and amazon
they pay higher fees to a firm because
consumers often spend more so consumers
say you know what not just the dress but
the shoes in the dress because i can
afford it i'll pay for it over time cbs
news business analyst jill schlesinger
worries sometimes it's too easy the ease
with which we can make these kinds of
transactions is really good for
consumers the downside is that we are
creating habits and behaviors that may
lead to more spending than we'd like
levgen says a firm helps protect some
consumers from themselves by denying new
transactions there's a difference
between buy now pay later and buy now
pay never it's never fun to be told
we're sorry but you cannot transact this
time and so it's this weird goldilocks
product that helps consumers helps
merchants
spins the wheel of commerce without
getting anyone hurt sweet agrees
it's actually helped me create a budget
um and it's actually given me the
opportunity to get the things that i
need
and pay for it within a short period of
time remember with bnpl's disciplined
spending managing your credit smartly
still falls primarily on you last one
but like everything with black friday
it's all about options
for cbs mornings mark strassman san
francisco
as a former credit card debtor it just
worries me because when you're spending
outside your means right that's where
you sometimes get yourself in the truck
no jerica duncan has a brilliant saying
living lean
within mommy that's right that's right
but not true these apps are popular with
young people as a young person back when
i was a young person
i'm a young person no back when i was a
young person got in trouble with credit
cards in college you know went to
daytona for spring break and realized
that i didn't actually have any money
because i wasn't working i was this
college student and so if you're
disciplined and you've got good habits
and good behaviors great that's the key
if you don't and i didn't
i'm with you
yeah exactly